[Music]
we have done our homework and research
and now we present to you the birth
years of the targaryen dragons as well
as their family tree which means which
dragons came from which ones so let's
get to it
the first ones are the unnamed dragons
who came with the targaryens to
dragonstone along with belair in the
black dread no information is known as
to when they were born
therefore they would have hatched from
eggs way before 114 years before aegon's
conquest which means 114 bc bc meaning
the years before the conquest
valerian was also one of the original
dragons that came to dragonstone and his
birth is before 114 bc
he died in 94 ac
of old age at more than 200 years old it
is said that the cannibal was already in
the island of dragonstone way before
aegon and his sisters came to it so it
is also very old hatching from its act
before 114 bc and living to be more than
two centuries old by the time of the
dance of the dragons
so since only female dragons lay eggs we
can rule out valeria on all the cannibal
or any other male dragon from being a
noodle point for the next generation and
here the branches of the family tree
really begin
the dragon miraxis was the first
targaryen dragon to hatch in dragonstone
but the exact date is unknown and
because she was bigger than vegar at a
time of the conquest therefore she is
older than her quicksilver was born
around 10 to 20 ac ac which means the
years after aegon's conquest but she was
killed by valerion at a young age and
therefore her line ended there
vega was also born from one of the
unnamed dragon's eggs in the year 52 bc
she would eventually grow to be nearly
as big as valerian by the time she dies
in 130 ac at 181 years of age we now
come to dream fire verma thor and
silverwing who were born around 32 34
and 36 ac which is more than two decades
after maraxi's death in tennessee which
only means that they hatch from vegas
clutch of x the only surviving female
doing a bit of research we found out
that melees was already a big dragon in
75 ac when alyssa targaryen chose her
and the same goes to karaxis who was
around the same age as melees being
claimed for the first time in
ac so they would have been born around
the year 50 ac
since there was no other mentions of
other female dragons other than silver
wing and dream fire
and also that dream fire's last batch of
eggs were laid around 49 ac
and the next generation cyrax sea smoke
sunfire and thesarian would have been
born around the year 95 to 110 ac which
is 50 years after the last batch of eggs
laid by dream fire therefore this would
only mean that they came from silver
wings batch of dragon balls
the young wild dragon gracos was a bit
smaller than sunfire that devoured it
greg host was also born between 100 and
110 ac
as for greek host the wild dragon we
have absolutely no idea where this wild
dragon came from as the other mentioned
wild dragons were males no females
vermax that bonded with jacares was born
along with him in 114 ac iraq's that was
bonded with joffrey valarion the younger
brother was born a year later in 115 ac
antaraxis with the youngest one lucerus
valarion was born two years after in 117
ac
a dragon egg that was placed in the
cradle of young prince aegon targaryen
not the conqueror
at his birth and hatched into a dragon
called stormcloud in 120 ac
strikers was bonded with a prince named
jaehaerys the son of aegon ii and was
born in 123 ac
morgul that bonded with princess jahera
was born in the same year in 123 ac
a young dragon moon dancer was born four
years before the dance of the dragons
between 125 and 126 ac
and the youngest dragon during the dance
of the dragons morning was her name and
was born in 129 ac two years before the
end of the war
then there were many small dragons that
were born after that and they dwindled
in signs and the last one the stunted
dragon was born in the year 153 ac
but there were another set of tree acts
of dream fire that were stolen and
shipped to esses and over the centuries
they became petrified and fossilized and
this is a theory mind you so these eggs
are thought to be the ones that daenerys
targaryen was gifted with in her wedding
therefore possibly they are the ones
that drogon viserion and rhaegal hatch
from which means these three are dream
fires offspring's direct ones
so that's it that's the video those are
the birth years of the targaryen dragons
and also the family tree so i hope you
have enjoyed watching this video do hit
that like button for support and
subscribe but most of all smash the bell
icon for regular updates on new videos
here on this channel till the next one
take care fam